good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today
is scp-2571
object class euclid
special containment procedures a
foundation-operated bot
io mandela is to monitor online
communities for discussions regarding
scp-2571
mobile task force size 7 the
laughingstock is to investigate these
discussions
and make a determination for appropriate
action on a case-by-case basis
description scp-2571 is a recurring
childhood memory of a non-existent theme
park
cragglewood park it is estimated that
0.05
of the world's population is affected by
scp-2571
however recent evidence suggests that
this number may be growing
the primary vector for scp-2571 spread
is not yet known
notably it appears to be most common
among adults raised as an only child
afflicted subjects are initially
responsive to amnestics but memories
regarding cragglewood will typically
resurface once treatment ceases
although descriptions of these memories
vary several details remain consistent
subjects were between the age of 4 and
12 when they visited
the park featured numerous characters
primarily centered around
anthropomorphic variants of trees and
plants no adult supervision was present
calliope music played throughout the
park
subjects attended the park with numerous
other children
none of whom they knew the park featured
only one ride
a carousel or merry-go-round although
children accompanying the subjects
boarded this ride
the subjects themselves did not
investigations regarding the precise
nature of both scp-2571
and cragglewood park are ongoing
addendum 2571.1
interview logs access
scp 2571 interviews
log 218 date
november 16th 2002
interviewer dr raynor subject
rupert tuckasu begin log
what do you recall about cragglewood
park
jesus is that what this is about
it's just a nightmare i used to have can
you elaborate
i mean i think it's it's probably based
on some actual
theme park i went to as a little kid you
know
probably traumatized the [ __ ] out of me
what happens in the nightmare
i enter this theme park it's like
disneyland but smaller there's no rides
just this long winding road through the
woods
everything's bright and colorful like in
a cartoon and there's all these trees
around me but
tell me about the trees they've all got
faces
and they're singing they've got these
dopey cheerful looks
like one of those old-time cartoons
right then they just sing
and laugh and sing can you tell me
anything else
there's this music that's playing
everywhere it's like
organ music but not the kind you hear in
a church more like the sword you might
hear in a carnival
you mentioned before that there aren't
any rights oh no wait
no i'm wrong there's rides there's one
ride
just one ride it's that thing with the
horses that goes around in circles
you know what i'm talking about a
carousel right that thing
it's where the organ music is coming
from were you there alone
no there was other kids with me they're
not happy to be there either
we're all smiling and laughing but we're
just doing it to stop
ourselves from crying you know to fool
the trees
so the trees don't see how scared we are
to keep the trees happy keep them
happy yeah is there anything else you
can tell us
um [ __ ] i don't know uh i haven't dreamt
about this place in ages
uh i think there's one bit near the end
please relax take as much time as you
need
just as i'm getting ready to leave i see
something
a tiny tree spreading up near my foot
it looks up at me it's smiling
smiling with that big dobby happy grin
when i see it that's when i start
screaming
that's when i wake up why does that make
you scream
because it has my face
end log access
scp 2571 interviews
log 341 date
january 9 2003
interviewer dr raynor subject
james yearling begin log
did you ever ride the carousel what hell
no
are you crazy what happened when you
reached it then
some of the kids got on not me though
the ones who did
some of them were smiling some of them
were crying
some of them hugged the ones who didn't
get on some of them hugged each other
what happened then they rode the
carousel then we left
what happened to them how should i know
we left
you left them behind yes we left them
behind
what you think we should have stuck
around see how this was all gonna turn
out
i'm sorry i didn't mean to accuse you of
anything you were just a child and no
one would have expected you that's right
i was just a goddamn child in the middle
of a goddamn nightmare and i
i just you have no idea what even
talking about this is doing to me
or how it's making me feel i don't want
to talk about it i just want to forget
it
why can't you just let us
let us i'm sorry
i just you don't need to apologize
mr yearling but you've clearly gone
through a deeply traumatizing experience
i i just i i don't understand
i can't imagine you would nothing about
this experience makes much sense
it's not bad it isn't just that it's
it's it's just what is it
one of the kids i don't want one of the
kids that got on
yes why why did he hug
me i'd i i didn't even know
who he was
end log access
scp-2571 interviews
log 367 date
june 12 2004
interviewer dr raynor subject
randolph blair begin log
i'd like to talk to you about the video
cassette
christ i understand this people just
don't get it
i don't want to discuss any of this with
you [ __ ] i shouldn't have told my
therapist any of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] please mr blair
i need you to focus
get on with it this cassette
where did you get it from i don't know i
don't [ __ ] know
i found it in my attic when i was
cleaning [ __ ] out i thought it was just
an old copy of
ghostbusters or something do you
recognize any of the images on it i
don't know
yeah from nightmares [ __ ] like that
maybe someone showed me the tape as a
kid have you lived in this house your
whole life
yeah you were raised in this house by a
parent
yeah is this going somewhere the front
bedroom
look i don't want to talk about this
[ __ ] okay
i understand but we need to understand
what's going on mr blair
why is the front i don't know i don't
[ __ ] know
it's just always had [ __ ] in it but
nobody uses it
that's why i keep it locked okay
i don't think about it i understand mr
blair
i just need to work on it i just need to
ask one more question
whatever mr blair
have you always been an only child
end log note the subject has refused to
conduct any additional interviews
addendum scp 2571.2
video log date june
10th 2004. the following log describes
the contents of a mini video cassette
tape
found in the possession of randolph
blair the word craggle wood is written
across its label
in black felt tip marker begin log
i'm scared it's okay it's okay don't cry
you have to smile you have to
[Music]
smile please just smile
be okay i promise
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm sorry
you have to go you have to no you can go
please i'm sorry i'll be okay just
[Music]
no
end log
nothing like an anomalous entity to make
you glad you have messed up dreams that
don't
feature cracklewood park
anyway let's conclude the lesson
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to louis
colon it's not a spoon
corey barker arbiter soul
darius tan james saba
eric kawaii fire keeper
daniel joger corvus
the commissar longinus
king madding samurai corgis
nj vujak and justin day
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vogen
thank you
you